hi i'm priyanka vergaria staff developer
advocate at google cloud and today i
plan to share with you some tips to get
into cloud without a degree let me start
by saying that yes it is a bonus if you
already have a degree within computer
science discipline but it is not
required
what is required though is commitment
and motivation as long as you have those
you can study and gain the experience
you need to get into cloud
so if you have the commitment and the
motivation what do you need to reach
your cloud destination
in this video i will lay out a four-step
path for you to get into cloud and
answer some common questions
first
understanding your cloud path which path
do you want to take a developer
architect data engineer machine learning
engineer a devops engineer security or
network engineer i know that itself is a
lot how do you choose
even though you may not have a computer
science degree your current or your past
experience might lie in let's say
networking or security or systems
administration
those experiences are a great way to
pick one of these paths it can
accelerate your journey into cloud i got
into cloud with sas services background
i know friends and colleagues who
started off as security engineers
because they had experience in security
if you have no background in any of
these paths that is fine no worries at
all you can still get into cloud the
path i would recommend in that case is
pursuing an associate level cloud
architect knowledge
why because it prepares you with a
little bit of everything from
infrastructure to networking to security
to data and more
which makes it a great foundational step
you can pick a specialization from there
or stick to being an architect now comes
the how
the second part which is studying for a
certification
each of these paths have a corresponding
certification if exams scare you like
they scare me don't approach it as i'm
studying to get certified just go
through the prep with an intention of
structured study you don't really have
to get certified but the structured
studying for a certification will help
you cover the concepts you need to know
to be successful in the cloud role
anyway whichever path you pick you
should definitely go through the
fundamentals of google cloud such as
google cloud skills boost coursera or
pluralsight courses
each of these have their own learning
paths defined on their certification
pages so go through and make a study
plan
that brings me to third step which is
doing the hands-on labs this is the part
that's most important you cannot skip
this one you need to see how things work
play with the tech
make a hello world this is the part that
is going to bring it all together
between the theoretical concepts and the
practical applications
where can you find these labs though
there are quick labs and quick starts to
get familiar with the concept you can
piece those together to build your own
fun projects
then comes the fourth point which is
building your cloud portfolio
your certification proves that you have
the knowledge but to prove to an
employer you will need to show that you
can put that knowledge to an effective
use for a business purpose and to prove
that
focus on creating a cloud project's
portfolio from your training journey or
from your internship or passion projects
now you might ask is getting a
certification and doing hands-on labs
really enough well
no on its own a cloud certification with
some hands-on labs does not guarantee a
job you need to demonstrate hard skills
how do you compensate for the lack of
experience
by working on hands-on projects pick a
project that spans across some
programming languages networking some
basic linux command knowledge and deploy
it in cloud so an example project could
be something like building an api or a
web application it will require you to
develop the code for your application
then you would have to pick the
infrastructure to deploy that
application in the cloud pick storage a
database to interact with in that
process you would basically end up
learning how the internet works the http
tcp ssl networking and more you might
ask will search help me bypass the
degree filters that recruiters set up
yes search do help get you interviews it
can open doors when a recruiter goes
through your resume having a search says
that you're serious especially if you're
missing a traditional college degree in
computer science
you might ask
what about those hiring managers will
they really hire me on the basis of a
sword or a training here's how i like to
think about it the cert can get you an
interview and the hands-on hard
experience will help you convert that
interview into a job
and don't worry about getting too many
search all you need is one or two search
to demonstrate that you're serious about
this
beyond that experience really counts a
lot more sometimes you might need to
spend some time in an intermediate role
like help desk customer support
design
for example i started off at a sas
company as a quality assurance engineer
one of the most common questions i get
is what if i have a degree in something
else that's not cloud i would consider
that a net positive find ways to
leverage your non-tech skills to make
you a more attractive candidate for
example i have a colleague stephanie
wong who broke into cloud with the
communication studies degree and she's
made that a differentiator for herself
in telling technical stories on this
youtube channel overall don't let not
having a cs degree stop you from
exploring cloud as a career
there is a path to gaining knowledge and
expertise and to find a job
we just covered it pick a path prepare
for a certification
do hands-on labs and build your cloud
portfolio now it's your turn go ahead
use these steps and make a plan for your
cloud journey and if you liked this
video give it a like and subscribe to
our channel we will be back with more
advice on how you can crack your cloud
career
[Music]